make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are getting into james tinion's batman
run
and we're i mean at the end of the video
we're going to talk about punchline a
lot of you guys have been asking about
her we don't really have any information
on her right but a lot of you guys have
been asking so i figured i would title
this you know punchline the the joker's
new girlfriend uh but she's had some
scant appearances and from what i
understand she's not really going to be
a major player
in in batman comics until we get to the
joker war but you guys have been asking
about her you've been asking me to dump
some information on her so at the end of
the video i'll give you guys what we
have in any event
here's the thing about james tinion's
run right and this is one of the things
to kind of be weary of when it when it
comes to
two stories right james tinian's batman
run is amazing so far but so was tom
king's
and the the issue was that by the time
he got to the end of tom king's run it
really kind of just seemed to be an
exercise in self-indulgence with a great
big huge story that really just didn't
go anywhere
it's possible tinyon's run could go in
that direction we don't really know yet
but the cool thing about this is that
tinian is writing batman
the way he's been writing detective
comics which is awesome because his run
on detective comics
is amazing like it's it's ridiculously
good i feel like it's one of the unsung
heroes of like dc right now right like
it's a super good story but what this
does
is it initially picks up uh seemingly
with a kind of coming together of
various villains right but the first
person we really pick up here with is a
character by the name of cheshire now
cheshire is a long-standing enemy of the
teen titans the the funny thing about
cheshire
is she's unique and you're really in
comparison to a lot of the different
like mercenaries and villains who are
out there
right because when you look at the
people who are here you have like mr
teeth which we'll talk about him here in
a little bit
you've got malcolm merlin kind of the
antithesis of green arrow and
the green arrow comics you've got you
know you got gunsmith who's actually a
pretty cool character in and of himself
uh and then of course you have a
fifth person here we'll find out who
they are here in a second but cheshire
among all the various
contract killers out there is unique
because of the fact that basically her
hair her fingernails things like that
are all tainted with different poisons
right so like at any point in time she
could scratch you and you could die
from like the venom of an ass snake or
in this instance where she killed the
the doorman the venom of what was
basically a box jellyfish like these
things are cool right
it's one of the things that makes her
really intriguing and really interesting
but it makes her difficult to capture
right because she's like a tree frog
right like like an amazonian tree frog
the the entirety of her body is
basically a giant poison and so if you
were to touch her you were to grab her
hair
or you were to be scratched by her nails
or bit by her or something like that or
even possibly touch her skin
you could die and so it's interesting
like she's really intriguing in that way
but what this also does is it kind of
switches over to catwoman now here's one
of the cool things here right with
selena kyle this is one of the things
that i love about what tinian's doing
that that tom king did differently
whenever tom king
had like batman and catwoman talking it
just didn't sound natural right it was
it was like watching an alan sorkin show
right so like the newsroom or like the
west wing where people have
conversations but no one really talks
like that in real life
and it kind of removed you from the
comic right like nobody talks that way
like when they would communicate and
things like that
tiny does a really really good job of
having discussions between characters
and it really just kind of feels organic
the way that selena kyle and batwoman
talk it's not the most important thing
out there but it is kind of a cool thing
the other part of this that you really
end up learning here is that bruce wayne
is kind of going or at least batman's
going headlong
into the notion of like developing
gotham city right he's going into the
notion of like developing gotham and
just making it a better place as opposed
to
i'm running around as batman and i'm
beating up criminals in the middle of
the night like i'm some kind of a
schizophrenic
and like and that's my that's my stick
that's my thing right like he's actually
working to improve gotham more so than
he ever did before and in fact kenyon
will kind of address
this unlike years past but the cool
thing is that what he ends up doing is
really kind of having this conversation
with lucious fox right where batman is
in the midst of developing this
not not really a batmobile but not
really a batwing kind of a blend between
the two to a degree which is somewhat of
an interesting idea but the big takeaway
from this is he basically says
that about five days prior on the dark
web that the the bat computer picked up
a message that was sent out and then
deleted three minutes later and what
this basically did was kind of sent out
a message to five
of the most capable assassins out there
in the world and basically said
meet in gotham city on this day and
we're gonna complete a mission and that
basically deathstroke is the one who's
leading them and this is an interesting
thing here
because batman really sort of analyzes
all the villains who were there and it's
just kind of like okay each one of these
guys are interesting you know mr teeth
and
gunsmith and cheshire and so on but the
only person that i'm really worried
about here is deathstroke
because for deathstroke it's about the
money but also about the principle if
somebody's gonna hire him for a job it
has to be worth
doing right because deathstroke has
enough money so it's one of these things
where he doesn't really need the cash
it's is it worth my while to even take
this job in the first place
which he can kind of command right he's
like the premier assassin
in dc comics so like if you really want
somebody to die deathstroke's the guy
you get a hold of so it's kind of
interesting and so because of this
batman's essentially planned for
for a lot of these villains to take them
down but also realizes that
deathstroke's mind operating as fast as
it does and in fact it's kind of
established here
nine times faster than the average man
means a batman has to act and then
respond
in really an exceedingly short amount of
time otherwise deathstroke will mentally
get the upper hand and this is an
important thing because what it shows
here is that while bruce wayne doesn't
really consider deathstroke to be an
equal he does consider deathstroke to be
somebody worth worrying about and
deathstroke is in a lot of ways and
equal to batman not you know strictly in
terms of fighting but in terms of his
ingenuity how his mind works his ability
to comprehend and understand situations
to get in and out of different scenarios
as fast as possible i mean for god's
sake the guy was facing off against
superman and just threw like glowing
green rocks at him and tricked superman
into thinking it was kryptonite right so
like small little things like that
are what really make deathstroke unique
and intriguing here so of course batman
executes this plan
and basically you know throws out what
are called the bat shadow casters and
what these are designed to do is
basically kind of emit a shadow that
more or less follows these various
villains around
and then tricks them into believing
they're leading batman into a trap where
they can somehow take him out when in
reality he's not there
now of course going toe-to-toe against
deathstroke is a cool thing to see
with death row being there him and
batman facing off against each other
it's largely been established multiple
times over dc comics that sometimes the
battle can actually go either way the
sometimes deathstroke can win but
because of his super soldier
enhancements sometimes batman can win
because batman's just the best fighter
in dc comics but regardless
you know basically what deathstroke says
here is like you fighting me this is the
distraction this is this is part of the
big plan right like this is all going
the way it's supposed to and batman's
response is i know exactly what's going
on like i know what it is you're trying
to do and that's what we basically pick
up with catwoman who followed a guy down
into uh this kind of sub basement with
all this information where the plans of
bruce wayne in fixing gotham city and
and kind of what it is that he wants to
do with the city as a whole are
intending to be replaced with a new set
of designs by a person called the
designer
and the cool thing about this is that
when when you know this happens when
this goes down and catwoman confronts
this guy
ultimately he's just kind of like you
have to stop this guy like i don't care
what you have to do but you have to stop
this guy's plans from coming to fruition
after which this guy immediately begins
to die kind of breaking down and so on
but a disembodied voice seemingly starts
to kind of come
out out of this guy's body and basically
saying like catwoman i see you i know
you're here
you know you have to understand this
plan that that was concocted some time
ago that you were a part of
it's now coming to fruition right the
designer is coming for gotham city the
catwoman immediately picks up on what's
going on and so what this does is it
hits back to this idea that somewhere
along the line and part of the of the
history of gotham city which we haven't
really known about before
that catwoman seemingly made a deal or
made some kind of a bargain with this
designer guy but we don't really know
how far this goes right just kind of
hitting at this idea that there's some
pretty clandestine stuff going on but
the cool thing about this
is that this rabbit hole goes down
pretty far and we'll find out how far
it goes but what this does is it jumps
to batman who basically jumps on his
communicator and says alfred
send the priority signal to the gotham
city police department and this is this
is cool because my initial thought was
oh my god gotham's back but it's
interesting to see tanyan kind of
picking up on what it is that tom king
did
and continuing that continuity because
alfred's dead and that's where lucius
chimes in and says alfred
isn't here anymore man like alfred's
alfred's gone batman and batman slipped
right he knew that that alfred was gone
but it was just one of these things
where he's so used to doing it
it's crushing for him to have to have to
admit that alfred's not here and he
actually just kind of you know seems to
cry i mean some of it seems like rain
but i would say batman kind of seems to
cry in response to this and so as a
result he basically tells lucious grab
that that ship thing you know we'll grab
the villains and we'll we'll take them
off
and that'll be the end of that and so
what you basically end up doing is you
end up jumping to riddler who's having a
conversation
with the penguin of course a penguin
killing various people who were there
and this is when things get cool because
what the riddler says
is i've been watching everything that's
been going on with gotham city i've been
watching all these things take place so
on and so forth and like the
the designer is coming to town right the
designer is here in gotham city the
response of penguin is
yeah i know and i've taken out anybody
who knows what it is that i've been
doing right who knows about my plans or
anything like that
literally all the villains are basically
cleaning house whoever this designer is
whoever this this
guy is here whatever whatever it is he's
capable of and and
whatever he's about is scaring the hell
out of the villains right it's scaring
them enough to where penguin is killing
off his henchmen so there's no one there
to drop any information
and the riddler's scared out of his wits
right the riddler's just like dude this
guy
is no joke and so it's it's kind of
crazy because you know we've seen things
with like bane taking over gotham city
so on and so forth the difference
between
this this you know the way this is going
down and what tom king did is that in
this story
you feel the stakes you're like okay so
like something's getting ready to pop
off in gotham
something really bad is getting ready to
happen but that's the thing is is the
riddler's response is
like the designer is coming to collect
the designer is coming for all of us
coming for all of us as the villains and
penguins responses
he can try and so this is when things
get interesting because from there you
pick up with the various villains
of course who have essentially been
apprehended by batman and what you learn
is you have this place called the black
bloc
and the black bloc is basically this
this prison that's designed to hold
people
that that are escaped escape dangerous
now the reason why this is awesome and
this is an amazing invention by by james
tinion because i'm pretty sure he's the
one who made it when you look at the
batman mythos and you look at like
arkham asylum arkham is for the most
part a revolving door right like
toothpaste or penguin or joker or any
number of those guys riddler mad hat or
whoever you know the
mr freeze they're busted by batman and
then it's only a matter of time before
they escape from arkham in order to
avoid this
what batman had done working alongside
lucius fox and really even the gotham
city police department was create the
black bloc
is a place where escaping criminals
rights like bain and joker people like
that who present a clear and present
danger to gotham city itself could be
held and detained but you basically got
10 feet of cement which is lined with
concrete
the idea is that like no one can get out
of here right like once you're in you're
in and there's only two ways in and out
of this whole black block the first one
is basically a dna encoded set of keys
that are only used by gotham city police
department and the second one is an
interest that only batman knows about
and so when batman gets in there
and starts talking to deathstroke
deathstroke is immediately like hey man
like you know i'm not going to tell you
who it was that hired me so don't waste
your time the other people don't know so
they can't tell you but here's the thing
one i'm gonna break out of here right
i'm not gonna be in here forever this is
a cool little game you're playing and i
like that you believe you can hold me
it's cute but understand i'm deathstroke
right like
i will get out of this place and then
two this is a game that you're playing
it's interesting to watch you play this
game because you're going to lose and
it's going to be fun to watch you fail
this is a game that you will not win so
wish me luck when i get out of here and
that's when batman basically tells
bullock who's basically operating as a
commissioner presumably because of the
events of the batman who laughs and the
fact that commissioner gordon is
basically there with uh with the batman
who laughs as part of his you know evil
group or whatever his evil justice
league who cares nobody's reading that
anymore the thing is
like when he basically has the cell of
cheshire opened up
batman rubs her face and then realizes
that it's clay that it's a body double
right like it's not
actually cheshire herself and so
immediately goes on the defensive with
lucious says track you know find
cheshire track her down they
successfully do they end up locating her
and
one of the most crazy things to come out
of this and this this batwing
you know ship thing that bruce wayne has
he shoots himself out of the railgun
he literally shoots himself out of the
railgun in order to track her down as
fast as possible because of the fact
that
the building she's traveling between are
too narrow for him to just like swoop
down and pick her up with like some kind
of a chain and then do like he did
in detective comics number 27 where he
just hangs her and this is like she's
better off this way but nonetheless you
know jumping out of here at least when
when
cheshire makes makes her move to try to
take out bruce wayne and then
immediately goes to basically dig her
nails into his uh into his skin
that the intention is that he's gonna
end up dying from whatever poison he's
exposed to now of course
this leads to uh basically cheshire
being hit by a truck while batman slides
underneath it and while it's not enough
to kill her it is enough to incapacitate
her and then of course batman reveals
that he basically had a kind of uh
membrane in his suit that essentially
absorbed the poison so you know
batman's plot armor strikes again but
then at that moment suddenly deathstroke
and all of his guys escaped from the
facility and that's when we basically
end up finding out here that what was
going on is that penguin basically made
his move right penguin had jumped in
here and penguin was the one who freed
all of these guys he's the one that got
them all
out of there which is kind of a cool
thing to see and so then what you do is
you basically jump to the riddler having
a conversation with catwoman that
catwoman's basically made her way to a
cemetery after that you know
conversation with with the one guy who
she believed to have been dead
ends up having a conversation with her
and basically saying hey i haven't used
this line for quite some time but you
have to understand
we all made a deal with the designer we
made a deal with him and he's coming to
collect
so you me anybody who was involved with
that we're all either going to die or
we're going to have to play ball the
indication is that the designer is going
to kill them all right that's the
indication he's going to kill
all the villains of batman that's why
this is so cool right because the stakes
feel so intense right it's just like
dude all the villains of batman are
going to die and it sucks especially for
count women because she's a good guy now
and it's one of the things
that's that's really kind of
communicated here when it comes to to
riddler izzy says the whole reason why
we got together with the designer was to
commit quote-unquote the perfect crime
but basically
you know house is being cleaned by all
of us me as a riddler i never really had
hinchman so i don't really have to worry
about that
i'm basically gonna like i'm getting out
of here like i'm jumping ship the
penguin cleaned house on his end
we have to assume that if there are any
other villains that are involved they've
done the exact same thing as well
but the belief of catwoman is that the
joker's somehow involved here
and so of course traveling to the
cemetery this is done for the intention
of finding the casket of the joker which
she does he's basically laying down
inside this casket now for those of you
guys who were unsure
or who who were kind of looking at this
like where did the joker die
this this basically appeared to have
happened back in batman issue number 49
by uh tom king as part of the lead
lead-up to the wedding that never
happened between batman and catwoman and
it was kind of like this killing joke
moment right where
where uh catwoman and and joker got into
a fight and then she slashed his throat
with her claws and then they had this
great big huge
long you know conversation basically
which tom king did with unnecessarily
with a lot of situations but basically
at the end of it joker seemingly died
right he just kind of seemed to have
been dead ever since now continuity wise
i don't know how that fits into doomsday
clock i don't think dc knows i don't
think they really care enough to to
figure it all out but the the long and
short of it is that
at the moment right now all indications
are that the joker is dead right so the
question becomes
if the joker's dead then how is his
disembodied voice communicating with
anybody who's out there right like
or seemingly communicating with her at
least this catwoman believed and so the
other part of this is of course batman
essentially apprehending cheshire is
then contacted by lucius fox who gives
him one of the coolest inventions
ever what he basically says is that
inside of your of your utility belt is a
device called the echo and what the echo
does is it basically allows you to
attach
it to any vehicle that's out there which
in turn will hack into the wayne
enterprises components within the car
and then basically allow the car's
appearance to change it creates a kind
of hologram but it'll make any car
look like a batmobile and then it'll
allow it to drive as fast as the
batmobile
which is cool because basically what
this means is that batman's got a
batmobile
in his pocket right like at any point in
time he can just slap this thing onto a
car
and then drive off now batman's response
is like you want me to jack a car
and then turn it into a batmobile and
then drive and lucious is like well it's
my car so you're fine
but nonetheless the funny thing is that
you know kind of switching back to
catwoman in the midst of this whole
thing where she kind of comes to
frustration with the fact that one the
riddler basically says i'm cutting this
line now i'm leaving there'll be
no more communication for between you
and me good luck with the designer
hopefully you get out in time but
understand that you're probably gonna
have to break this news to batman
something that you know it's this kind
of ultimate betrayal more or less that
you committed against him without him
really knowing
she's also met with the arrival of these
these two kind of henchmen of sorts you
know who basically show up and then
essentially you know almost kind of
knock her out or knock her unconscious
and then start burying her there
along with the joker you know and so of
course picking up with the penguin
you know the penguin basically there
with deathstroke and all those guys is
kind of like look like here's the deal
i'm i'm skipping town we're like i'm
getting out of here i don't want to have
anything to do with the designer i know
the designer was the one that hired you
guys
i will pay you double your rate if you
guys leave gotham and then you guys
sign a non-compete clause basically you
won't return to gotham within a calendar
year and the response to deathstroke is
you couldn't afford my price right so
you can't even afford double my price
and then in turn
intends to go and kill the penguin only
for batman to basically show up and then
of course you know he's kind of told hey
man
just so you know like dr you know
attaching the echo to any car does not
give you the kind of armor that the
batmobile has so just keep that in mind
man
it's just a hologram right so if they
shoot you it's you're probably gonna die
if you get shot in like the jaw or
something like that somewhere where your
armor doesn't protect you
but for the most part the various
henchmen who are here are overtaken like
that right i mean
they're for the most part taken out
quick fast and in a hurry by batman at
which point the you know deathstroke
responds
stop like if you keep fighting i'm gonna
kill the penguin and so it's cool
because malcolm merlin grabs cheshire
the villains make their escape and
deathstroke
slices the throat of the penguin and
it's dude like when this happened
i was like holy cow dude like dude is a
penguin gonna die
the classic villains of batman are
basically being killed off you know so
of course this leads to deathstroke
making the smart move it's the smartest
move for him to make right
knowing batman as he knows him he knows
that batman will not let the penguin die
right batman despite all the glitz and
glamour and all the stuff that he does
is a champion of life right so he's not
going to let the penguin die
and so deathstroke knows this and he
essentially says you have one of two
choices either you can come after us
and you can let the penguin die or you
can save penguin but we know you're not
gonna let him die we know how this game
is gonna play out we'll see when we see
we're gonna go after our targets and
basically they end up leaving while
batman goes to save penguin himself and
so with that going down
the penguin in turn spills the beans and
basically says
years ago right you never knew about
this nobody ever told you but years ago
myself
joker catwoman like riddler the
underworld essentially united to commit
the perfect crime
and the perfect crime was to take out
bruce wayne right to ally ourselves with
the designer and the designer's goal was
to take out bruce wayne that these guys
here right these you know deathstroke
and all those guys they're there to take
out false targets
the way this looks like it was supposed
to go down is that batman was not
supposed to know what was actually going
on that instead you'd have these
criminals who showed up here they would
take out false targets baton would chase
around try to figure out what's going on
and the designer instead would basically
take out the plans of bruce wayne to
destroy what it is that he wanted to do
with
gotham city itself the other indication
here is that if the designer is looking
to take out bruce wayne that would seem
arbitrary right like i mean he's just a
really rich guy as far as the world's
concerned
all anybody you know aside from the
justice league and the individuals who
know that bruce wayne is batman bruce
wayne is just a really rich guy who's
trying to make gotham better seemingly
the indication here is the designer
knows that bruce wayne is batman like
that that kind of seems to be what the
case is now there you know
it's cool to see that because then you
switch over of course to catwoman and
catwoman basically kind of digs herself
out
you know she's like i'm not gonna die
here like i'm not gonna die buried alive
in a grave with the joker's corpse like
that's ridiculous you know she kind of
ends up jumping out and then
of course is saved by none other than
harley quinn which is kind of crazy
because it's like why the heck is harley
quinn even here
which is kind of nuts now of course from
there the penguin is basically dropped
off
at like a gotham city hospital by batman
literally batman grabbed the penguin
drove to this location out of the
vehicle
left him on the steps of the hospital
and was like i got stuff to do and then
left
is kind of screwed up but batman ends up
going after these false targets right
now this is important
because what this shows is batman is
trying to do it all right now the
reality is batman wouldn't let the false
targets die right that was the whole
message of the penguin you know gunsmith
and uh
mr teeth and and cheshire and uh and
deathstroke you know so on you know
they're gonna go
after the false targets and they're
gonna kill them right so innocent people
are basically going to die if batman
chose not to go after these guys and
that's kind of the danger of all this
right like the designer really seems to
be orchestrating things in such a way to
where batman's being pushed to his
limits and in a lot of ways he is
because this comes
hot off the heels of everything that
just happened with city of bane the
death of alfred and all that kind of
stuff right and so kind of going after
the gunsmith we sort of get a run down
on this guy this guy's name is douglas
worth and basically he was a veteran you
know of half a dozen military
contractors as it's explained by james
tinion and then ultimately was fired
from each and every one for using
experimental weapons in the field
without any kind of approval whatsoever
but the reason why he got his name
is it basically he kind of fashioned a a
you know a silencer
out of different things that he found
from an electronic store and then killed
a guy on a plane that was full of people
and no one knew that he did it right so
he was just that capable but the issue
is that at the end of the day despite
you know his his his capabilities with
fashioning you know weapons seemingly
out of just arbitrary components kind of
kind of being like this macgyver sort of
situation he's no match for batman right
so he's taken out
with a quickness right i mean that
happens quick fast and in a hurry
following that
is mr teeth and mr teeth sort of gained
his name because of the fact that what
he was doing was going through and
and killing people uh and then
surgically removing the teeth from their
mouth and then surgically putting them
inside their stomachs right now why he
was doing that we don't know probably
because he's just crazy as hell but of
course he's taken out by batman as well
with a quickness right the other thing
behind this is that they're currently
you know he's currently in the lair of
the
uh of the riddler and so the indication
seems to be here that these five guys
were basically tasked with tracking down
the classic villains of batman
catwoman the riddler penguin or
presumably two-faced the joker you know
these major members of the criminal
underworld they're each going to take
out one of them
and of course mr teeth was here to take
out the riddler and so with mr teeth
being removed from the equation this in
turn allows batman to basically analyze
the
the only real footage left there by
riddler by edward nigma which was done
of course
intentionally for batman to follow up on
and it's cool to see that james tinion
does this right it's cool to see him
look at this and say okay let's still
maintain this role of the riddler what
edward enigma was doing is that when he
was confronted by the designer he was
making a series of hand gestures
and these hand gestures were essentially
you know a riddle more or less
on a keyboard of sorts they were more or
less a riddle and batman understanding
and deciphering this you know picking up
this riddle is basically the question
what walks on four legs in the morning
two legs in midday and three legs in the
evening and the response solution fox is
well man
i have no idea how that makes sense but
of course you know batman figuring it
out basically says okay
this essentially grants them access to
the computer systems which basically
shows them that the riddler was running
a track that nobody else was whether
batman wasn't or anybody else wasn't
which was on deathstroke and so that of
course
gives him the location of deathstroke
which batman you know sends out his
little bat drones in order to track him
down
but what this does is that from here it
switches directly over to batman and to
catwoman you know catwoman and harley
quinn showing up and then catwoman
basically saying like we need to talk
like we need to have a conversation
i need to tell you about all of these
things you know that it's a guy called
the designer that he's basically here
now batman for the most part
knows what the penguin told him but he
doesn't really know everything and so
it's at this point when catwoman
apologizes that we get into essentially
the new girlfriend of the joker a lot of
you guys have been asking about this a
lot of you guys have been asking me
questions what's going on with the
girlfriend of the joker this is all we
have right this this is it it's
basically just a girl who calls the
joker and is just like hey they've seen
the grave but their attention's been
drawn elsewhere and the joker's response
is okay like i have something else to
attend to where like i mean i have other
people to talk to before this goes down
this is it guys like this is
all we have with the girlfriend of the
joker i don't understand why people are
freaking out over it i mean i get it
insofar as it's the joker's new
girlfriend but aside from this
and like an appearance in hell arisen
there's nothing else here right like
she's not gonna be a major player until
april or may when it comes to joker war
all we're gonna get is these little
teaser one page moments and that's
basically gonna be it right so this is
kind of
kind of strange to me you know in terms
of of people getting super hyped up and
everybody asking me about it right it's
like people who are asking me to explain
the one below all in marvel comics we
don't know enough
we can't explain it because we don't
know enough and we don't really know
anything about her all we know is that
she's just a character who's there and
that's basically it but the big takeaway
from all this is the joker is alive
right the joker is very much alive we
don't really know how
but the joker is very much alive maybe
he's one of the three mysterious jokers
and that's essentially it
and then you end up picking up with
harley quinn who's basically controlling
a bunch of these these weapons belonging
to batman and is sending them after
deathstroke right so
so this part of the story kind of kicks
off you know it picks up with a bang uh
and it's kind of a cool thing because
what it does is it switches back over to
catwoman and to bruce wayne now one of
the things that james tinion kept going
after the events of tom king was the
relationship between catwoman and bruce
wayne and a lot of people really liked
this right it just kind of made sense
one of the things that always kind of
threw me off about tom
king's writing was the way that batman
and catwoman talk to each other just
never really seemed organic
james tinnen really seems to correct
that right tom king's writing was a
little weird but james tinning really
seems to correct that
and basically giving us this seemingly
organic conversation between the two but
because of the fact that catwoman was
one of the
the initial individuals who dealt with
the designer she's the one that
basically has all this information and
the response of batman is i need you to
tell me everything that's going on and
so what this does is it gives us a kind
of flashback with the origin of the
designer himself
and so far as it's given to us here and
what we basically learned is that at
some point in the past seemingly around
20 years ago
you know seems to be the the indication
that catwoman was
basically just a kind of burglar right
she was in her in the early days of her
career but there was a kind of
legend of a guy named the designer this
this individual out there that was
responsible for pulling off some of the
greatest heists that ever happened
it's cool here because he was almost
kind of like this mythical
enigmatic figure right he existed but
it's one of these things where people
were just kind of like
this guy's more myth than actual fact
and so what ended up happening
is that there was basically a card sent
to catwoman that was essentially an
invitation from the designer
to meet at a particular location when
she arrives there she's met by the
riddler she's met by joker and she's met
by penguin all of whom have
been invited as well and they're
seemingly brought in by this guy on a
boat which is kind of creepy
in terms of how he looks it's almost
like crossing the river sticks right
where like you have to pay the coins to
the guy on the boat i don't remember
what his name is he has an actual name
in a greek and roman roman theology but
uh but unless they're they're basically
brought to this house right it's called
the house of tartarus uh where they meet
with the designer for the very first
time
and it's kind of nuts here because the
designer sort of pops up and and really
says like when he's talking to the joker
he's like you're the clown prince of
crime like your reputation precedes you
the indication here is that the designer
knows everything about these guys now
when they are brought here their weapons
are basically handed over to make sure
that nothing pops off but it's kind of a
cool thing the other cool thing about
this is the designer looks amazing right
in terms of his design he looks
absolutely awesome
but it's kind of a cool thing because
what we also end up learning is that
with
this guy here with the designer in his
past he had basically come across a kind
of detective and there is more to this
story but we'll figure out you know what
that is later on down the line but this
designer had basically faced off against
this detective and ultimately found what
we basically see with batman comics all
the time that the villain fights the
good guy and the good guy always wins
because a good guy is always one or two
steps ahead the designer kind of found
himself in this constant struggle of
always losing
because the detective he was fighting
was just that much more intelligent than
he was
and he came to the realization that in
order to win he has to out-think
the detective more so than that it can't
just be a plan the detective doesn't
expect
he has to be so far ahead that by the
time the detective realizes there's no
chance for him to win he's already lost
and ultimately the designer ended up
spending a year inside of his own
facility right his own kind of base of
operations for lack of a better word and
just kept coming up with all these ideas
and all these plans that were so
advanced and so nuanced the detective
never saw them coming
and the only real indication we get here
is that the detective was not actually
killed by the designer instead he was
left essentially disgraced right he was
left disgraced
and for the most part the world seems to
have lost faith in him and ultimately he
just ended up dying
seemingly of old age but it ended up
dying you know realizing that he was
defeated by
what seemed to be either his greatest
foe or any one of the many foes that he
faced off against but the designer
proved to be successful in that regard
and so what it does is it basically
allows the designer to tell the the
various people
these various villains this story and
then say i can help all of you achieve
your goal now it's
interesting the way that tinian writes
this because the villains really just
kind of
seem to go along with it right i mean
the reputation of the designer really
seems to kind of solidify that he's a
guy that deserves to be believed but
there's no guarantee that his reputation
is really accurate outside of the
various rumors and hearsay that the
villains have heard
and so we're just kind of left to assume
that the designer is is actually correct
right he can do this stuff because his
reputation is such
that the individuals who are telling the
story are beyond contestation as far as
these various villains are concerned but
it is a pretty cool concept here and so
with catwoman and with the riddler and
with penguin meeting with the designer
in turn
they all kind of come out really a lot
happier than they were going in because
there seems to be truth to the idea that
the designer can help them achieve their
goals now the whole reason behind this
is the designer can get rich right he's
like i'm going to help all of you
achieve your goals but i want half of
all your earnings right i want half of
everything you take
and then we'll just you know you'll
never hear from me again and so finally
the designer meets with the joker and as
we know the joker is really kind of a
wild card you never really know what's
going to happen and so
somehow we don't really know what was
said but the result was that when the
joker had his conversation with the
designer the designer immediately comes
out and it's just like kill them all
[Laughter]
so whatever the joker said piss this guy
off nice and good not only that uh with
everything popping off right like all
these
all these forces of the designer coming
after all the various villains who are
here the joker ends up revealing that he
still has a gun that he kept hidden and
he shoots the designer in the head and
that seems to be the end of him not only
that the various henchmen of the
designer are taken out the joker
seemingly killed everybody here it is
kind of nuts because it's like what in
the world could the joker have possibly
said to this guy that would have led to
this
becoming what it was not only that you
also end up having the villains here
saying okay then we're gonna sweep this
under the rug this is gonna be our dirty
little secret and that's kind of the
secret they were referencing
in the video that we that we did last
time right they all kind of share this
this mutual secret we didn't really know
how deep it went but basically the
designer was the guy who was gonna help
them achieve their goals none of their
goals could be achieved without the
funding of the designer which really
seemed to be kind of the plan right like
i'll tell you how you can achieve your
goal but it's all for naught if you
don't have the financial backing to do
it right the money to be able to pull it
off and so they have these plans with no
means to achieve them and so they end up
kind of sweeping the whole thing under
the rug but for the joker himself
will they burn tartarus house and just
kind of leave it there the joker is kind
of staring off of the distance and
that's when catwoman comments that she
began to realize how evil the joker is
going to become
because the joker basically knows what
his plan is he knows what he can do
and the joker could essentially find a
way to bypass
the finances needed by the designer and
then in turn pull it off on his own
anyway
not only that when catwoman finishes
this conversation with batman
batman comes to the realization that the
plan of catwoman was to basically rob
him
her plan was to rob bruce wayne and so
if the designer could help her achieve
that goal then the designer knew
that batman is bruce wayne not only that
the designer knows how to access his
family's wealth meaning
batman could seemingly lose everything
and so what it does is it switches over
to the joker you know basically in the
modern day talking to a bartender you
know essentially drinking what looks
like uh looks like a margarita
but he kind of starts telling the story
from his perspective and basically says
that during this meeting they had with
the designer
that the designer basically said i can
help you guys achieve these various
goals right and so
ultimately he said like each of you guys
will get a boon you'll basically get
some kind of financial backing so on and
so forth and so ultimately
the penguin wanted to be king of gotham
city right he wanted to be the mayor he
wanted to be the one to run the show the
riddler wanted to be the smartest person
in gotham city and catwoman wanted to be
the wealthiest but with
joker sitting down and looking at this
and realizing that there would be no
room for
the designer in gotham city itself the
joker came to the realization
that what the designer intended to do
was help them achieve their goals and
then with nobody else there
take them all out and then seemingly be
the only one to conquer gotham city
or the indication is that joker was the
one who wanted to do that but basically
what he told the designer is
if you're the devil then i want to take
your place i want to kill you and i want
to be the one to conquer gotham city and
that seems to have been the reason why
the designer kind of freaked out because
the joker was the one that seemed to
pick up on what it was that was actually
happening again
this is joker and the way he tells his
stories are often times ambiguous in the
sense that
we don't know if they're ever true we
don't know if he's ever really telling
the truth but again what it does is it
basically picks up with deathstroke and
batman on you know batman hot on his
trail the fact that harley quinn is
basically kind of blowing through all
the various devices of batman and batman
isn't chiming into lucious fox and
saying like shut down her control of
these things she's basically spinning
money like water through a sieve that's
not okay
that's the problem bruce wayne
ultimately manages to track down
deathstroke and of course he ends up
taking him captive or at least you know
deathstroke jumps onto
onto the batwing and then just starts
like attacking it and and so on and so
forth one thing that does happen here
is catwoman ends up locating harley
quinn and then the two of them basically
leave
for track down the designer or something
along those lines they're met by a
couple of
joker eyes members from the gotham city
police department this kind of seems to
be partially a scheme of the joker we're
not entirely sure here but what it does
it allows a kind of
battle between batman and deathstroke
now the reality is that this has kind of
been done to death
right batman vs deathstroke but what
makes this interesting is the
conversation between the two because
what you end up having here
is deathstroke and batman really having
this conversation where batman kind of
looks around and says like down there in
gotham city there's nine million people
and ironically enough their faith in
their government actually went
up when bain took control it's one of
these interesting things we talked about
that in the city of bain
story arc like people would say god you
know it's terrible that bane took over
gotham and all that kind of stuff but at
the end
according to the people there he made
the city a better place that batman's
not really willing to do what it takes
in order to actually win this bat that's
the interesting thing about the batman
mythos is i hear people kind of create
these arguments all the time of like
well if that were the logic then like
superman should kill his villains and
spider-man should kill his villains and
so on and so forth but batman
categorically and unequivocally has the
worst most
violent rogues gallery in all of comic
books and that's why there's a
legitimate case to make there and saying
that batman should kill all his villains
right because this city of gotham would
be better off with all those various
villains dead it's cool because batman
kind of looks at this and says yeah like
this city is the way it is because of me
and it's one of these things where he
almost kind of tries
to play it based on like well you know i
mean my parents died when i was a little
kid they were shot in an alley and i was
i
had to go down this path and all this
kind of stuff and deathstroke's not
buying it he's like at the end of the
day man you can you can come to me
whatever story you want to
but you escalated we were criminals
doing criminal things you're the one who
donned a cloak and cow and then you're
the one that started taking us out the
way that you did we had to step up
because you stepped up you're sort of
left asking the question right if bruce
wayne becoming batman is what led to
criminals becoming more violent
then is batman really the reason why
gotham is the way it is
were criminals ever going to become that
that violent in the first place or did
they only ever really get that way
because of batman it's interesting to
look at it for the other you know from
the other side of the equation and so
batman tries to reason with deathstroke
and it's like look i'm trying to change
the fact that i've gotten
extreme in recent years because he has
batman's become more and more extreme as
comics have gone on you look at like
silver age batman and then you compare
him to like
batman from like infinite crisis final
crisis the new 52. batman's
gotten more and more extreme over the
years because remember it's all just one
cohesive continuity now right so batman
has gotten more extreme over the years
and where he's like i'm trying to change
this extreme nature but what i need you
guys to do is to basically slow down and
stop the response of deathstroke is
no that's not going to happen right like
we're not going to slow down we're not
going to stop and so batman basically
like
just lunges at him and sends the both of
them flying off the batwing and
ultimately
deathstroke calls his bluff right he's
like look man you can do this all day
long if you want to but we both know
you're going to shoot one of your your
bat
grappling guns right so just do that do
the damn thing and then save us right
and that's exactly what he does right he
shoots a grappling hook and basically
ends up saving him in deathstroke and
that's essentially it and
it's kind of a funny thing because
deathstroke can essentially play batman
like a fiddle batman's predictable
there's just a line that batman won't
cross
and because the villains know batman
won't cross that line at the end of the
day
he's always only ever a half measure
because it's kind of like i won't do
what needs to be done
in order to save gotham city because i
don't believe in killing but my parents
were killed and you know yada yada
and so on and so forth but sometimes
it's in the best interest
to kill a villain right it's it's in the
in the interest of people by batman not
killing his villains all he's doing is
sacrificing innocent lives right he's
saying like the
thousands of people that that joker's
going to kill over the course
of a year or several years or something
like that they are not as valuable as
the joker's life right the joker being
redeemed
is more valuable than those innocent
people and that's why it's always an
interesting question
how many lives is batman willing to
sacrifice before he says
enough is enough because in the end if
he has the means to kill the joker but
he doesn't he is in effect
sacrificing those people's lives and so
where the the designer finally pops up
to batman and basically says you know
deathstroke you're done now
indicating to deathstroke that he's
going to get screwed over on his
contract batman's kind of like you know
come and face
me and the response to the designer is
no we still have one more game left
and that's when edward enigma the
riddler pops up and says the entirety of
gotham city is now under my control i've
split the entire city
into what's basically a giant crossword
puzzle and there's these enormous walls
as tall as buildings you know and it's
like everybody stay put where you are
the only way the entire city is going to
be let loose uh is if batman's able to
correctly solve this crossword puzzle
if he guesses wrong then i basically
blow up a bomb right and the indication
here
is that if he guesses like three across
and like
four down and he gets it wrong that
section gets destroyed with a bomb
and so lives our lives are basically in
jeopardy here this is the kind of thing
i'm talking about right like this
wouldn't be a problem if edward nigma
were dead
and so it's it's it's kind of
interesting because ultimately lucious
fox cannot really locate where edward
enigma is where the riddler is and
enigma just starts cutting off batman's
communications in order to force him in
a situation where he has to use his own
wits in order to be able to pull this
off and it's kind of cool because
this is an insane amount of hubris on
behalf of the riddler because where this
kind of starts going down
batman ends up of course taking uh
taking deathstroke who's currently
handcuffed and then takes him to like a
batman train
literally batman has a bat train and so
while that's happening while batman's
facing off against these these forces of
uh
of the designer who are seemingly kind
of coming out of nowhere and waiting on
this train to arrive
then you end up having riddler who's
asking these questions right one across
nine spaces the more i take the more i
leave behind batman's response
footsteps joker comes in eight down five
spaces what has many keys but can open
no doors batman's response
piano he's answering all these things
like that right just off the top of his
head and this is james tenon really
showing the intelligence of bruce wayne
this is one of the most important
aspects and it's one of the coolest
things right because like when you look
at snyder's batman run
what made what really showcased bruce
wayne's intelligence was the small
things right now some of that was
because
it's batman comics batman can't die
because you know he's just too popular
for dc to kill off he just sells too
well right and so that's why batman
always comes out on top
but to see a display of his intelligence
like this just constantly countering
edward neighbors questions
every every time he asks a scenario
batman basically answers almost
perfectly right 10 across 11 spaces a
woman shoots her husband holds him under
water for five minutes
hangs him and then takes him out to
dinner how is that possible the response
of batman photography she took a picture
of him
right being able to like counter every
single one of edward nigma's riddles off
the top of his head with the greatest
of ease despite being completely battle
worn and totally exhausted
shows how far above edward enigma batman
really is and that's where enigma starts
getting pissed off
and that was always his weakness right
in comics that was always the weakness
of edward nigma
he would let his temper get the better
of him if batman started getting the
better of him
it was just kind of a it was it was
always the thing that ended up catching
him off guard now from here this picks
up with catwoman and harley quinn
in a pretty interesting scenario right
we end up finding out what it is that
that harley quinn and catwoman are
actually up to and in reality it's just
catwoman harley quinn's just kind of
along for the ride
but we end up finding out that what
catwoman is looking for is someone
called the underbroker
and this is an individual who basically
has access to essentially every bank
account
across the entirety of gotham city you
can you can access anybody's account
using the help of this particular guy
now catwoman says that she has the
account numbers that she is a member of
their club in good standing
and this basically leads to catwoman
being allowed in by the underbroker
himself
the issue with this is that as catwoman
gets in there they're meant by the
arrival of
punchline the punchline is actually
there not only that this is when harley
quinn
meets the joker's new girlfriend for the
very first time and
it is cool because harley quinn doesn't
initially know that instead it's just
kind of like punchlines like i'm here to
make a withdrawal too i'm the punch line
i'm where you end it's kind of a lame
phrase to have but it is a cool thing to
see them encounter each other because
when when harley quinn's like who in the
world is this person catwoman's like
she's the joker's new girlfriend and
harley's like oh this girl's in
for a time you would think harley quinn
would be pissed about being replaced
right like oh no
no let me tell you something harley
quinn is often imitated never duplicated
that's not the response right that's
that's not what happens instead harley's
kinda like okay so like you're in for a
rough ride like i know it seems cool to
be the joker's new girlfriend at the
moment he's gonna screw you up in ways
that you can't even begin to imagine yet
not only that harley's whole thing is
like are you funny because you don't
really sound funny and like punchline
tries to make a few sort of veiled
threats and outright threats and tries
to make a few jokes here and there but
at the end of the day harley's not
buying it she's like i've been around
this block more than a few times you got
nothing
you got nothing no jokes no puns no
anything you are a poor
man's harley quinn and then she
basically tells her like in a few years
and a few dozen cries in the shower and
so on and so forth i'm gonna buy you a
frozen margarita and we're gonna have a
girly girl chat about how you made the
worst decision of your life but until
then i'm gonna bash your head in with a
hammer
and immediately attacks the girl i love
that not only that of course catwoman
ends up getting her hand on the
underbroker and then we end up finding
out you know who this guy is right that
his name is harlan graves this guy has
all kinds of information but
catwoman knows everything about him as
well and so it's like if you if you
don't tell me what i want to know i'm
going to start spewing all your private
information
for harley quinn and for punchline to
hear and if you don't want me to do that
you're going to take me to a computer
terminal to get me where i need to go
the reality what seems to be going on
here is that if the designer does have
the plan of catwoman which was to rob
bruce wayne and seemingly has sent
punchline for that purpose to access
that computer terminal then of course
catwoman is there to basically withdraw
those funds or to move those funds to a
different location so the designer can't
get his hands on him right so bruce
wayne doesn't lose everything
and so with that being the case batman
ends up tracking down the riddler after
he recognizes where it is the riddler's
at
he takes out the riddler right it's not
a great big huge thing riddler's not
really physically capable in comparison
to batman the riddler's taken out pretty
quickly batman basically
knocks out deathstroke with a
tranquilizer dart that's enough to keep
an elephant
asleep for a few hours so on deathstroke
it'll probably work for like half an
hour 45 minutes you know because of his
healing factor and so batman is
basically kind of met by the arrival of
the designer who says you know it's cool
you've unraveled all your adversaries
designs that's awesome but it's not
going to be enough
because you must know that if i'm in
bruce wayne's office
then it means i must know who you are
and the designer confirms that and
saying
hello bruce wayne it's time that you and
i have a conversation before i kill you
you know the fact that the designers
here now really kind of gives us a
perspective into what's going on
because what you get here is batman
basically telling the designer tell me
how this goes right give me the scenario
and the designer's response is
no like if you've already deduced it
then you tell me what happens and so we
kind of get this big explanation in
terms of how it was all supposed to go
down right so
this is how the designer's plan was
originally going to unfold in the city
of gotham before everything went belly
up with the joker and all those guys
right so
initially the idea was to bring in five
of the highest paid assassins the best
paid assassins in the whole world right
and at that point in time back then when
this was all kind of
brought together initially right because
the actual plan of the designer took
place in the past uh it would have been
deathstroke deadshot lady shiva kg beast
and merlin now the whole idea behind
them was to basically launch a
simultaneous attack
all at once in the city of gotham not
against the entirety of the city's
populace but instead against those
individuals who would basically
be in the line of succession when it
comes to the fall of the mayor right so
you'd have the mayor who will be taken
out
the deputy mayor the public advocate the
city comptroller and the majority leader
of the city council right so they would
all be taken out
in one fell swoop just all seemingly
happening in almost an instant
this would lead to batman basically
jumping in and starting to investigate
but what it would also lead to
is the penguin basically becoming mayor
of gotham city now as the mayor this in
turn would move to the riddler and the
riddler would lock down the entirety of
the city of gotham but what he would do
here is he would operate on two fronts
the first front would be a ruse it would
basically be welder you know riddle me
this
and all the puzzles and all that kind of
stuff the truth about it was to
basically isolate the nypd precincts
and then only those individual police
officers who were basically willing to
come forward
and swear loyalty to the riddler would
be allowed to navigate from one location
to the next but what it would do is it
would lock down entire precincts and it
would make it easy to take out
a multitude of different cops right
because if you don't have to worry about
police officers running all over the
place going underground hiding different
things like that you can just start
taking them out in huge chunks
other precincts don't know what are
happening to other precincts because all
lines of communication are effectively
cut off
it would make it easy to basically take
control of the entire police uh the
entire police force or at least get rid
of those who were who are not loyal and
keep those who were loyal this goes into
catwoman and because
catwoman would be the one that would
basically be dealing with the money she
would effectively hack into
all the various accounts of the richest
man in gotham city bruce wayne and she
would come to the realization that the
wayne foundation is actually funded by
offshore accounts and the way this would
work is she would basically have all
those different account numbers in hand
she would drain
all those assets and then redistribute
them accordingly based on whatever the
plan calls for but what it would do is
it would basically
make her the richest woman in all of
gotham and then in turn she would be the
bank for all the various criminals that
are out there the place where they can
they can save their money they can put
their money there and then using those
various offshore accounts she can run
those that run that money
offshore and keep it hidden away from
everybody this finally goes into the
joker and the joker's task was simple
the joker
would kill batman and robin it's the
only thing that he would do and it
seemed to be the only thing that joker
really wanted to do and with
all of that happening the designer
essentially would allow the various
criminals to take out and and
really conquer the entirety of gotham
city in one fell swoop
it would happen almost overnight right
it would happen so fast before batman
even realized what was going on
when he first began the process of
investigating they would be
miles ahead of it right they'd be almost
done with their plan by the time he
first started his investigation into
what was going on now a lot of that was
based on
batman's inexperience at the time the
fact that he wasn't that great of a
superhero i mean he was but in terms of
his detective skills he's learned a lot
over the time that he's been
operating as a superhero and so to
capitalize on that
lack of experience would allow the
designers plan to come to fruition and
so ultimately batman's response is you
know i'm not the man that i was like i
have evolved i caught up to your design
and i am equal to it now and so this
leads to the two of them getting into a
kind of sword fight of sorts now
this jumps back over to to catwoman and
catwoman coming to this realization that
kind of going through and accessing
these different accounts that the wayne
foundation
is actually funded through offshore
accounts and it seems pretty shady right
because the way that it looks for for
anybody out there the way that it looks
is there's just a whole bunch of other
corporations out there or companies out
there who are all basically working
alongside wayne foundation and they're
probably looked at as like
subsidiaries or something like that but
basically bruce wayne himself doesn't
really seem to own anything
in reality it's all money that's owned
by uh by wayne enterprises but this is
also beneficial because with bruce wayne
being a person who operates as a
superhero operating as batman he doesn't
want anybody to know
how that money's being spent and the
truth is that if there was a breadcrumb
digitally or physically in terms of
actual hard cash
somebody would come looking right
somebody would be able to trace that
that breadcrumb and then ultimately draw
the conclusion the accurate conclusion
that bruce wayne is batman and so in
order to remove
any possibility of him being tied to how
the money's being spent with regards to
things going that basically batman would
use uh it's kind of a it's using a
series of shell companies in order to
hide it and so it's kind of a funny
thing because catwoman for the most part
knows all this right now the underbroker
the person who's you know who's who's
well really she's not really doing it
he's not doing his own volition like
she's basically told him that she was
gonna dump his identity if he didn't
help her uh but this guy has no idea
that bruce wayne is batman right in his
mind it's just this guy's probably up to
some [ __ ] uh some some cd stuff
and that's basically it but regardless
the response of catwoman is
we're going to drain all these accounts
right like you're going to drain all
those accounts and you're going to put
them in
in my account right you're basically
going to put these accounts in my name
and i am going to become the richest
person in gotham now keep in mind
catwoman isn't doing this in order to
take revenge on batman
she's doing this to ensure that bruce
wayne can remain batman and not lose all
of his money
right that's the really the only reason
why she's doing this at this point
remember you know her stance on the
whole plan and everything all has kind
of changed over the years and so
following this what we do
is we jump to probably what you guys
want to see most which is harley quinn
versus punchline now punchline we don't
really know much about her history her
origin or anything like that but the way
that she fights harley quinn really
seems to show that she's a pretty
top-notch fighter she's by no means
prodigious right because harley quinn's
not the greatest fighter there ever was
right fighting her is not like fighting
deathstroke
or somebody like that but at the end of
the day you know she's you know having
this conversation with punchline talking
to her punchline basically saying that
like at the end of the day harley quinn
wanted to fix him she wanted to make him
better and why she wanted to water him
down basically into nothing uh then
ultimately punchline looks at joker for
the way he is
and is in love with it and so the
response of harley quinn is you're a
groupie
you're basically a joker groupie but the
the idea behind punchline is that it's
not really about that right it's not
really about any kind of
physical gratification that she gets
from being with the joker if there even
is any what makes him so interesting to
her is that the joker could conquer
gotham city and harley quinn could have
been there for the entire ride but she
didn't want the joker for the way he was
she wanted to
wanted the joker for the way she wanted
him to be now that wasn't initially how
it all went down right holly quinn was
initially in love with the joker
that's one of the the many origins of
her character but the long and short of
it is that she always in some form or
fashion was enamored by the joker the
role he played the way he saw the world
all that kind of stuff
and where she was kind of swept up in
that it wasn't until she began to really
see what the joker was about then she
started to see that she was better off
without him and so as time began to
begin to progress he started seeing
these stories in in dc comics where
harley quinn would leave the joker she'd
go off and do her own thing
the joker would run would basically run
her out like he would kick her out she'd
go and do her own thing whatever the
case was
she kind of began this process of
separating herself from the joker more
and more often
until eventually she just walked away
right she was basically left the joker
in his entirety and he'd just been
operating solo that entire time but it's
kind of crazy because one of the funny
things is that punchline seems to be
highly enamored the same way that harley
quinn was and she even goes as far as to
say that like the joker says i'm the
funniest person he knows well the
response of harley who's been around
this block more than a few times is like
yeah but he says that to everybody right
like he said that to batman he sent it
to
an old nun who couldn't talk anymore
like he's the joker he jokes like that's
what he does right so if you're really
buying into what he's telling you as an
absolute truth then you're an idiot
like he's a bad guy right like he's a
villain and the responsive punchline is
maybe he is you know and maybe he will
hurt me one day but i'm gonna hurt you
first she manages to get the upper hand
on harley
and then slices her throat following
that they toss her body into the water
and then she in turn
starts to go after uh starts to go after
catwoman it's kind of crazy to see
punchline take out harley quinn that way
but picking back up with batman and the
designer again the two of them sort of
going at it and continuing to fight so
on and so forth one of the things that
batman figures out is that the designer
had
underestimated gotham city right the
designer believed he could just kind of
roll in here and basically starts
pitching these ideas to these various
criminals on ways in which they could
topple batman and robin and then take
the city for themselves but the reality
is
that the designer underestimated the
joker and he underestimated gotham city
given his plan and the nature of what it
is that he wanted to do at the end of
the day
it would only really work if joker was
willing to kill batman and robin but the
truth is the joker didn't want to he
wanted to kill everybody else but he
didn't want to kill batman and robin and
it scared the crap out of the designer
because the joker couldn't be explained
he couldn't be rationalized right he
couldn't be categorized he wasn't
somebody that was just based on
simple a simple desire to to acquire
money or anything like that right
like it's like the dark knight he just
wants to watch the world burn and that's
really what the designer didn't grasp
when the
when the designer first showed up here
he thought the joker was just a petty
serial killer right and like appeals to
his to his vanity or to his desire to
acquire wealth or to vengeance by taking
out batman and robin would be all he
really needed to be on board but when
the joker was was brought in by the
designer and the designer learned what
the joker was really about that he was
really just a madman he was an
absolutely insane person he didn't care
about the identity of bruce wayne and
robert i'm sorry batman and robin he
didn't care who they really were he
didn't care about killing them that in
fact he wanted to keep them alive and
just make them suffer by killing
everybody else the designer realized he
was beyond any real
ability to be reasoned with and so
ultimately this cost the designer his
life and when batman pulls off the mask
the designer
is actually dead right he's basically
just kind of like this shambling shell
as batman refers to it and ultimately
he's being controlled by the joker and
that's when batman asked the question
what are you doing like why attack me
like this what are you trying to prove
now batman had figured out the joker was
controlling the designer seemingly some
time ago this is not really an
indication that that's
that's actually true but probably part
way through this fight he seemed to
figure it out
and the response to the joker is like
it's not my plan to break you right
that's what comes next
like i have a whole year to do that
right so you know obviously teasing
joker war but his whole idea is i needed
to break
her in order to break you right so in
turn like batman realizes it's catwoman
that he's going after and so immediately
deathstroke jumps in right deathstroke
was tasked by the joker for completing a
task deathstroke managed managed to
sneak into this place who managed to get
into this place with batman distracted
and in that moment
stabs him through the leg with a sword
and normally it wouldn't really matter
but the idea here is that if batman
pulls it out he's gonna bleed to death
right so he basically he's basically
kind of stuck here at the moment and he
has to figure out what it is that he
needs to do next right like some kind of
a medic is gonna have to be sent over
here by
by lucius fox there is no alfred anymore
right so it's not like alfred can tend
to his wounds or anything so batman's
got to figure out what to do and in that
time he needs
to figure out what it is that he needs
to do that allows the joker's plan
to continue going and that's the benefit
of all this right it's not really the
grandiose nature of the plan
that provides its success it's the
precious moments in between
each step that provides success right
the fact that batman has to stop and
figure out what he's gonna do
for like five or ten minutes is all the
time the joker needs to achieve a
particular goal that's really what
you're talking about here right as fast
as the mind of bruce wayne works his
ability to react almost instantly right
whatever that case is this means the
joker has to be able to respond
accordingly and all this stuff
seems to have been prepared for and so
switching back to catwoman once this is
all done and catwoman's work is finished
and all this money has been transferred
to essentially another external account
then the response of catwoman is remove
all my information right delete all my
account information all of it has to go
and
at the end of the day the response of
the under broker is well i mean your
account like your account is
is actually quite empty right like you
believe you are transferring all this
information to your account and you
believe that what we were going to do
now was remove your account from this
database so nobody else could access it
but there's nothing sent to your account
your account's dead because you were
never sending money to your account in
the first place without happening
there's a gunshot we end up finding out
punchline pulled the trigger catwoman
is essentially down for the count and
then in turn she calls the joker and the
joker asks the question is it done and
she says yes
and the joker says say it i want to hear
these words and the response is
joker you are now worth over 100 billion
dollars this initially picks up with
bruce wayne in his younger years
and bruce wayne is more or less just
kind of waiting on a guy like wait just
sitting kind of sitting at a table
doing these little designs of gotham
city it's kind of funny because he
basically says they were they were never
really a design for the city uh the dark
designs were always for him
right uh but he ultimately ends up
basically you know tracking this guy
down finding him
and then basically following him and he
basically tells them look like i
followed your clues
uh i know you're in there like i know
who you are uh you know i need to talk
to you and ultimately you know bruce
wayne kind of makes his way
in and this guy basically says or at
least bruce reveals this guy's name
is cassandra wyclef baker now for those
of you guys who are following our story
or at least following the dark designs
this guy was the nemesis of the designer
right the the guy that the designer
basically spent all this time trying to
track down or at least trying to defeat
spent years and years and years in a
room creating a plan so that by the time
this guy baker figured out what was
going on the plan was already almost
done right and baker's days were
essentially finished the other funny
thing about this too
is that baker basically you know
indicates he knows who bruce wayne is
right he knows exactly who he is which
isn't really the biggest thing in the
world but it's like from batman begins
that like bruce wayne would have to he'd
have to try to travel 2000 miles to find
somebody who didn't know his name
but the the way that james kenyon really
kind of hits on this
to really show how good of a detective
this guy is is he says like i can tell
from the cut of your jacket which port
of japan you traveled here from right i
can tell you
uh where you learn the art of the katana
right i can tell you where you were when
you learn how to how to slow your
heartbeat i know
all these things about you right the cut
of your hair tells me where you learn
how to fly the calluses on your hand
tell me where you learned to forge metal
like i know
all these things about you i know
everything about you just by looking at
you that's how good this detective was
right that's how good baker was you
could take
one glimpse at bruce wayne and then say
i know everywhere you've been within the
last you know however long
and when bruce asks how could you
possibly know baker kind of reveals this
secret room where he he
has like all these pictures all over the
place right and it's kind of like this
this is everything i know about this
place right everything i know about you
everything i know about everything i've
seen
all kinds of stuff and he says i'm going
to teach you the most important lesson
i'm not going to teach you how to be a
detective i'm going to teach you how to
lose
and that's a super important thing here
and on the surface it's easy for
for you to kind of be like okay that's
weird right and to kind of write it off
no
it's not necessarily important to win
it's important to know how to lose
because if you know how to lose you know
how to understand why you lost you know
how to correct the reason you lost and
then you know how to win because the
reality of this
is you don't win 100 of the time right
it's like that line from ocean's 11
right
like because the house always takes you
right no matter how long you play if you
play long enough
the house wins unless when that perfect
hand comes along you bet big and then
you take the house
that's basically what this is right it's
batman being taught at a very young age
you're going to lose it's going to
happen right it's inevitable but what
you have to learn is how to recover from
that loss and how to go forward
accordingly and so what we end up doing
is picking up in the immediate aftermath
of the last video that we covered right
the last comic where basically batman
was stabbed through the leg by
deathstroke now a lot of people kind of
looked at it as though it was some kind
of a joke right like batman stabbed to
the leg you know what's the case it's
not just a random leg stabbing right
like deathstroke hit an artery now
technically if you really want to kill
batman in 30 seconds he would have
stabbed him in that artery right down
there in the groin right you'll bleed
out
like that right it'll take no time at
all but he stabbed him in a location
where it's like one of these things if
you pull it out you're gonna bleed to
death and that's why lucious fox was
basically contacted to get in here
because it bought deathstroke
time right they brought destroyed the
time he needed to basically leave right
so lucious fox has to get here batman's
not going to go anywhere he's not going
to go running out because any major
movement he makes takes the risk of of
you know exacerbating this this
stab or this this injury with the sword
so he's gonna have to just wait until
lucius gets there then lucius is gonna
do whatever he has to do he's not a
medic right he's not alfred he's not a
trained doctor right so he's gonna do
whatever he can
and then there's a time for batman to
recover however long it takes for him to
recover that buys deathstroke a
breadth of time and when you're talking
about a scenario like this all
deathstroke really needs is like half an
hour to 45 minutes and he's on the other
he's he's on a plane
gone out of gotham city and who knows
where he's at and this is also
singularly more important because while
batman wouldn't normally have the
resources to track deathstroke down if
you wanted to remember
all those resources are gone now right
so you end up having basically lucious
fox who who kind of just throws like a
compression
bandage more or less uh onto you know
onto onto batman which does enough to
kind of keep the keeper from bleeding
out all over the place you know it's
more or less just kind of like taking
your hand and covering over the wound
and putting pressure on it that's all it
really does it's a stopgap measure right
the response is like bruce you have to
go to a hospital and get some kind of
surgery done or something like that
because if you don't
you're just gonna bleed out and so what
lucius does is immediately start
dropping all this information
right like batman tells lucious like
they have my they have the fortune now
right joker has
all my account numbers all that
information he's got everything about me
and the response of lucious is yeah i
know
lawyers have already seized your house
like you're you're wanted for embezzling
millions of dollars which we know
bruce wayne was doing or at least that
seemed to be the case that like bruce
was funneling money
he was embezzling money out of the
company into foreign accounts and wayne
enterprises itself was doing that
running through foreign banks bruce
wayne's wanted for all of that right so
he's wanted by the law
his fortune's gone he has nothing right
it's just like there's really nothing he
can do and the response of lucius fox is
i would love to be in your corner the
way that alfred was i'd love to be the
guy who would be here and help you every
step of the way but if i'm gonna fight
this off i have to operate as the ceo of
wayne enterprises i can only keep them
at bay for so long so i can't be in your
corner
i have to go take care of this right and
it's one of these things where he says
if i was alfred sure i'd be able to do
that right because alfred was a swiss
army knife alfred did
everything but i'm not alfred pennyworth
i'm lucious fox
and all i can do is the best that i can
do and so in turn you have batman who
asked were selena kyle right you think
he would have asked that already because
it's a woman he's gonna marry but he's
like worse than a kyle and the response
to lucious is she was shot she's in a
hospital uh and then he's just like
give like like i want to talk to her
right now where lucious is a little
hesitant about that focusing more on the
health of batman that he's getting ready
to pass out you know batman's like i
don't want to hear any of it i want to
talk to selena kyle and this basically
leads to lucious kind of putting his
daughter on the phone who put selena on
the phone and selena's kind of in and
out of consciousness right she's barely
making it she's just slightly
unconscious and it's one of these things
where where batman kind of
hits at where he feels like he fell
short right where he feel like where he
feels like he kind of screwed up it's
one of the great things kenyan's focused
on here
and it's one of the elements that's
fallen under the radar right there was
this really really good moment when
batman confronted deathstroke and they
were kind of going back and forth in
this argument and deathstroke was like
you were the one who
who like like you stepped it up first
right like you were the one that made
things worse first we were criminals who
were doing things you stepped it up
against us
right like you exacerbated the situation
and batman's response was
yes i know and that's really kind of how
bruce wayne was right that bruce wayne
was a kid who's whose parents were shot
in front of him and he's been crying
about it his whole life and he ended up
going through all these different
training sessions learning all these
different things
and when he came back to gotham city he
didn't meet with an equal force he met
with overwhelming force right he
hammered him it's like was it the dark
knight uh the the dark knight film he
hammered and hammered and hammered all
these different guys to the point of
desperation he's the one that made
things worse that instead of responding
to them with an adequate force he
responded with
more than what he needed and that's what
made things worse in gotham city it was
batman's actions that push people
further and further and it's what made
things more and more extreme not only
that he
you know because the life he lived
because of the person that he was he
systematically
pushed away everybody that cared about
him right everybody that mattered to him
he pushed
every single one of them away and it led
him to where he is right now this was
not the life selena kyle was
banking on selena kyle joined up with
batman because she was expecting a
better life she was expecting things to
improve but batman made them worse and
so the result of this is that he
basically says like i'm gonna go and i'm
gonna try to clean this up and i'm gonna
try to make sure everything's sorted out
you know hopefully you can forgive me
and hopefully you'll be here when i get
back but he's like i'll just i'll kind
of be waiting on you and it is anger and
in his rampage of course he smashes a
window but lucious fox is kind of
shocked to hear that batman's actually
going to go out right he's got he's got
a stab in his leg where he's just
bleeding out but he's going to go out
there and continue to fight anyway it's
one of these things where batman's
making a stupid choice
he's making a stupid decision that he
seems to kind of be overcome with
emotion but the reality of this is when
he kind of chimes in and he says lucious
it's not just vengeance here it's not me
just pissed off because my money was
taken
and i'm really really mad he's like
there's a bigger picture at play here
the joker has all my resources
he has everything that batman had he's
got all the batmobiles he's got all
everything in wayne manor he's got all
the money he's got all the technology
everything that i use in order to
function as batman
is now in possession of the joker so
here's what you're gonna do
you're one you're gonna call up leslie
tompkins who most of you guys know is
the one that basically she's kind of
like the the night nurse from marvel
comics right she's the one that
basically runs a free clinic where she
tends to the injuries of various heroes
some villains depending on what the
situation is and then he basically says
like what you are about to see
in the city of gotham is gonna be an
attack from the joker and it's gonna be
like
nothing we've ever seen before right
because this is not the joker
flooding the city with joker toxin like
he did during endgame it's nothing like
that
this is joker on a whole new level it's
the joker with advanced technology and
with insanity
who in the hell knows what he's going to
do right and so you kind of switch over
to deathstroke for a moment and this is
kind of a quick throwaway thing and it's
easy to ignore
but it's massively significant because
you've not got deathstroke talking to
lady shiva and or i guess cheshire is
really what her name is
but uh but but you know she's kind of
like nobody here is they're all kind of
pissed off that they were used and
deathstrokes like i don't really care
you know they were getting paid well for
it and when she asked like what are you
doing he just says like nine million
people
and she's like what and he's like i'm
just taking one last look and like
literally looking at the city of nine
million people
which is about to devolve into absolute
chaos and pandemonium switch over to
batman who goes to get catwoman because
he knows joker's gonna start coming
after everybody when he gets there she's
gone he has no idea where
where catwoman's gone to she's just
vanished now initially the implication
was
the joker's henchman showed up and
snatched her up no the joker's hispanic
are there and they're like it was a
smart move getting rid of catwoman so
they don't know where catwoman is
and and where they kind of make this
offhanded remark of you know i doubt the
boss would care if we had some some
crossfire some casualties and they asked
him and joker's on the phone and he's
like no i really wouldn't mind i'm in
such a good mood go ahead and take out a
whole floor if you want to
right and and where batman asks the
joker do you have catwoman he says no no
she bailed the second that she was
stitched up right she
saw this coming man i don't know why you
didn't but she saw this coming
right like maybe she knows your real
bae's back in town who knows but
whatever the reason is she's
out of here right like she basically
ended up taking off and that's when the
joker starts to taunt batman he's like
oh you're bleeding out you gotta go and
get yourself stitched up man because of
the war that i'm gonna bring you i want
you at 100
because i want you to know that when you
lost to me you didn't lose because of
some technicality you didn't lose
because you weren't functioning at full
capacity i want you to know
you lost to me when you were at your
best right i have your money i have your
house
i have your company the joker's like an
ex-wife right like i have your house
your car your company i have the kids
i have it all i have the dog hell i even
took the goldfish like
it's it's nuts right the joker's like i
have everything of yours
man i have everything that belongs to
you i'm going to take
all these toys that you've been building
in wayne enterprises
i'm going to take all these things and
i'm going to use them
right like for years and years and years
you've been fighting me
and i've been using the resources of an
abandoned toy factory well guess what
that's not the case anymore man you're
totally alone you have none of your
resources you have none of your money
you have
nothing at your side you've got no
family you've got no girlfriend you've
got no butler you are
absolutely and totally categorically
alone it doesn't look very good for you
that's what's so crazy because the
joker's like i've got designs for the
city man
i've got designs for everything i'm
going to tear this city from the ground
up and i'm going to rebuild it all
and you're going to be the one that pays
for it all he says so let's get this
started he says
boys fire they open city on batman just
starts spraying down batman jumps out of
a window
you immediately switch the catwoman
right she wakes up kind of seemingly out
of the middle of nowhere and we find out
she was rescued by the penguin that the
penguin's like man this is like this is
this is a pretty wild situation like
it's initially you know she kind of says
well you know when he asked about the
designer she says the designer's dead
right joker's been playing us this
entire time and and the penguin's like
okay
like you're you know i can let you into
the private lounge this private lounge
is called the cool room right
this whole place basically houses and
it's actually so cool to see the mad
hatter again
i haven't seen him in a while uh but it
houses basically almost all of batman's
villains right and the response to the
joker is like this place is basically a
safe house that when things pop
off this is where we go like when things
are bad enough the whole city's in
jeopardy this is where we basically kind
of hang out at until things get terrible
i don't see kite man
which really kind of sucks right i'd
love to see kite man hell yeah but
nonetheless uh you know when when
countless says like i need to get out of
here
the response of the penguin is that's
not possible this entire place is in
lockdown right it's a joker attack which
is kind of wild right to hear that like
when the joker decides to attack gotham
city this is how all the villains react
right there's no like holding the joker
off it's like okay guys let's all go
into lockdown let's go underground you
know the penguin says hundreds of people
probably even thousands are going to die
we're sitting this one out
right so like buckle in catwoman it's
going to be a long
bloody summer it's nuts and so you end
up switching back over to batman who's
just kind of amusing to himself right
talking about everything that he had
learned from alfred how alfred always
wanted him to strive for better how
alfred looked at bruce wayne who was
kind of governed by this notion of
vengeance and was kind of like you have
to become better and
and bruce wayne finally kind of buys
into it and says yes you know with the
entire city with with me being the only
thing that i have left
yes i ask you for a signal what do i do
and he kind of gets one in the form of
like an electric storm and he says
i will become a better batman right now
we don't know what this means
that's what this is so cool that's what
makes it so cool we don't know if bruce
is like yes i'm going to become a better
batman i'm going to be more ruthless
i'm going to be more cruel i'm going to
be i'm going to be like i was after
jason todd died
basically until like tim drake showed up
into my life and became the new robin or
if he's like i'm gonna be a more
honorable batman right i'm gonna make up
for the failings that i had when i
initially became the guy that i became
is it gonna be a batman who works
alongside
all the other villains to take out the
joker we have no idea we gotta wait to
the next issue with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like now i'll catch
you all later peace
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
you